nokia a effectivement annoncé un plan de
réductions très important de sa
recherche et développement en france
cette recherche et de développement et
d'ailleurs pas uniquement orientée vers
la 5g mais elle couvre cet élément là et
c'est vrai que le retard pris peut-être
un peu léger par la france sur cette
dimension est potentiellement un des
éléments auxquels nous devons être
particulièrement vigilants pour éviter
ce genre d'annoncé et je vous confirme
et je serai très directe que nous avons
demandé à nokia de revoir l'ampleur de
ce plan est d'accompagner de minimiser
le nombre de départs volontaires mais
permettez moi de vous dire que ça fait
cinq ans que nous sommes aux côtés des
salariés pour les accompagner pour faire
en sorte que la france est l'un des
seuls pays voire le seul pays à avoir
été protégés contre des restructurations
dans cette entreprise
et ça c'est un fait autre fait également
nokia a permis de sauver alcatel qui
était malheureusement et c'était il ya
quelques années dans une situation bien
difficile vous le savez comme moi dans
une situation qui a conduit d'ailleurs à
faire ce rapprochement qui était
malheureusement la seule façon de sauver
des emplois en france
sauver cet acteur européen qui est
aujourd'hui confronté à une concurrence
très importante d'un autre acteur opéra
ericsson que nous accueillons et pour
lequel nous allons essayer de monter
dans les prochaines semaines un centre
de r&d également donc il ya aussi du
positif dans ce secteur mais également
huawei qui est très accompagné par son
gouvernement
donc nous allons agir aux côtés des
salariés sachez le nous sommes
aujourd'hui à la manoeuvre nous avons
reçu hier les organisations syndicales
et nous pousseront un nokia juste dans
leurs retranchements pour obtenir les
meilleures garanties pour les salariés
pour notre recherche et pour notre
souveraineté